the Tasmanian devil is unique to
Tasmania and is the islands unofficial
mascot it is a rural cleaner playing a
vital role in the ecosystem by devouring
carcasses that might otherwise lead to
disease full-grown Tasmanian devils are
famous fighters their ferocity is
legendary particularly when it comes to
food once these scavengers find a
carcass in the forest it's a feeding
frenzy
[Music]
pound for pound Tasmanian devils have
the most powerful bite in the world
designed for ripping open carcasses and
crushing bones wildlife photographer
Chris towbars sets out on a journey
which will make history
he is hoping to photograph the elusive
nocturnal creature that Tasmanians
called the devil but nothing in the
world could prepare him for what walks
in front of his lens
[Music]
what he photographs looks like something
out of a horror film suddenly another
grossly distorted Tasmanian Devil
emerges from the dark and then another
what is happening in the forests of
Tasmania what is creating these
disfigurements it's given the name devil
facial tumour disease or DFTD it's a new
strain of cancer the fact that there was
no record of this sort of disease showed
us we had a new problem Devils seem to
have a new problem
Tasmanian Devils have been found with a
new kind of cancer three different
locations same disease but where has
this cancer suddenly come from on the
Australian mainland the devil is
believed to have been wiped out by
dingoes over 400 years ago the island is
the last devil outpost but for over a
century Devils were hunted and poisoned
by farmers by the 1930s their numbers
had fallen to a dangerously low level
and killing devils was outlawed in 1941
now when they started to build up again
because they started with a very low
number of Devils we obviously got quite
a lot of inbreeding inbreeding means
Devils are genetically alike so their
immune systems recognize the infectious
cancer cells as their own cells and
don't fight them if the Devils were more
genetically dissimilar the cancer cells
would appear to be alien and their
immune systems would respond most of the
devil's here are very closely related so
the wrong disease can go right through
the population and that's what we're
seeing the mystery the mutant devils is
solved
the ultimate challenge is next how to
save the devil